new years in Nepal a time for
celebration and for piety Hinduism is
the main religion here and at this time
of year the devout fill the streets
where they ask for good fortune in the
new year and the men endure elaborate
tests of strength and endurance but the
village of bow day demonstrates its
religious devotion unlike any other
there just one man will stand before the
gods and undergo a painful trial his
name is Krishna Chandra and with
thousands watching he will allow a spike
to be born into his tongue if his tongue
does not bleed it is believed the gods
will grant his village prosperity in the
year ahead
in Nepal the new year starts in April
when fields have just been planted and
people are praying for a good harvest in
BO day that prayer comes in the form of
a sacrifice according to legend the
village of bow day began it's unusual
ceremony
four centuries ago to mark the end of a
very dark time a forest demon had been
terrorizing the town when the villagers
finally caught him they paraded him
through the streets his tongue silenced
by a metal spike ever since bow day has
celebrated the new year by reenacting
the demons fall its tongue piercing day
krishna has not eaten in three days part
of the preparation for his ordeal on his
way to the ceremony krishna stops to
pray at every shrine and temple
everywhere the gods have visited in the
square the crowd begins to buzz with
anticipation ASBO days mayor takes the
stage once on the platform Krishna is
greeted as if he himself were divine the
blade has not been sterilized there's no
anaesthetic the priest
Babu Kashi just dabs krishna's tongue
with oil to lubricate it
[Music]
[Applause]
his tongue does not bleed for the 11th
year in a row krishna has passed the
most crucial test
[Applause]
but his ordeal has only just begun
now he must carry a heavy bamboo icon a
symbol of the god Shiva through bow days
cobbled streets Krishna ends his walk at
the town's main temple just as he
crosses the threshold
Babu Kashi removes the spike from his
tongue as a lasting testament to
Krishna's and the town's piety the spike
is nailed to the temple wall Krishna is
free to head home to break his fast and
for the priests Bablu kanji and the rest
of the villagers this painful ritual has
once again served its purpose